at cooperation and the program includes
different topics including social
engineering culture arts new media and
among other things practice-oriented
block for the participants from the CIS
states and since we are on the soil of
Orenburg region traditionally when we
are in regions of the Russian Federation
we tell about their international and
inter-regional
work and activities and Orenburg region
is one of the dynamically developing
subjects of the Russian Federation in
that has reached natural resources very
effective agricultural sector transport
and energy infrastructure dynamically
growing financial and credit
institutions and thanks to its
geographical situation this region has
great strategic importance for the
southeastern frontiers of our countries
and it brings together Europe and Asia
and many come here actually in order to
see the point where the two continents
meet where the to cultural and not just
geographical spaces come together and I
remember when I was a little girl they
told me that this is the point that
marks the border between the two but
today it's more of a point which is
rather associated and signifying the
unity and at least this is the purpose
of the work of our country of our
external policy and this is also the
focus of the work of various
international organizations structures
and countries of the region and now
going back to the Orenburg region i
would like to say that international
relations are working thanks to 29
agreements with various international
Unity's various states and we trade
relations with over 80 countries of the
world and receive positive dynamics in
external trade and in 2018 it amounted
almost to 3.4 billion dollars and main
products are fuel energy and products of
ferrous industry the export mainly
includes machine engineering fuel and
energy chemical industry and ferrous
metals and main partners of the region
are Kazakhstan USA Belarus is Pakistan
Italy Korea China Hungary Netherlands
Turkey Lithuania Tajikistan and Japan
and here we have 4 364 plants which
worker thanks to cooperation with
capital of 439 countries and we
construct industrial plants agricultural
complexes construction develop
transportation communications trade and
welfare services and despite economic
sanctions imposed by Western countries
various European companies not only
maintain the existing partnership
relations but actually study the
opportunity to increase their
participation and this region has great
potential for also health resorts and
one of the most important spirit of work
is tourist and Recreation cluster salted
lakes the famous city of salt Alette
and we also work on developing
ecological tourism and physical stores
to study local flora and fauna and we
have created a center for restoring the
population of Russia Wolski's horse we
all remember about it from our study
books and we also cooperate in the
cultural sphere and humanitarian sphere
introduced various cultural and
commemorative events exhibitions and
every year we celebrate we conduct this
cinema festival east and west and
invite various artistic groups and arts
figures from all over the world and here
we have four representatives over over
126 nationalities and to have here a
unique cultural complex national village
where people can learn about history
culture and way of life of various
ethnicities and every year we conduct
International Economic Forum Orenburg
region the heart of Eurasia and here we
receive there is authorities commercial
circles and experts of Eurasian Economic
Commission as well as neighbouring and
other foreign countries and this region
is an important platform for the
Eurasian Economic Union and here we go
back to our traditional agenda and I'll
start with the agenda of the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs of the Russian
Federation mr. Lavrov on the 25th August
the Ministry of Foreign Affairs of
Russia will host the negotiations
between mr. Lavrov with the Minister of
Foreign Affairs and Trade Promotion of
Malta and we plan that the ministers of
our countries will talk about the
present state of affairs in our
political dialogue as well as
development trade economic cultural and
humanitarian relations between the two
countries as well as most relevant
international issues including Russia's
interactions with the EU OSCE
Council of European state of affairs in
Syria Libya and Ukraine and the
negotiations will take place as part of
the private visit of the head of the
foreign ministry of Malta which is
planned for 18th of August in this state
Museum Tsaritsyn are due to the opening
of an exhibition of Dmitry Levitsky
portrait of you Catherine Catherine the
second from the collection of the
presidential palace in Valletta and on
25 August Minister Lavrov will also make
a presentation at the inauguration of
the historic and documentary exposition
1939 beginning of World War two and here
we will have materials from the
ministries Archive which reconstruct the
actual turn of events and the real
reasons behind the world conflict and
the culprits and the events will receive
the head of the Rose Archive and head of
the Russian History Society
among the organizers we have largest
federal archives including Russia's
archive of military history and the
Department of History and documentation
of the Ministry of Foreign Affairs of
Russia and today judging by the news we
receive from other region from Moscow
region where mr. Lavrov spoke at one of
the very popular fora the Church of
meaning and based on the news we
received from there I read that he and
as his meeting and negotiations with his
German colleague and I can give the
details on 21st 22nd of August will
receive the working visit of the Federal
Ministry of Foreign Affairs of Germany
and the head of the Foreign Ministry of
Russia will meet with his colleague on
21st of August conducting negotiations
and the ministers of our countries will
talk about the key issues of the
bilateral agenda as well as will compare
the agenda of political context they
will focus on inter-regional and inter
societal connections as well as
scientific educational culture and
humanitarian and trade economic aspects
they will deepen their interaction and
exchange of opinions on the situation of
with international problems including
situation in Ukraine serious well
situation around Iran and global
stability and strategic security now
going passing to the international
agenda and Russia's approaches to
important international aspect the
situation in Syria is still rather tense
and we see serious situation in Italy
escalation zone the militants of the
Theresa lions head of Russian continued
firings against the Russian military
facilities and attempts of Russian Syria
to introduce on
the 2nd of August this ceasefire regime
were ignored and we saw over 200 cases
of breaches of the ceasefire regime and
there are victims run among the peaceful
population and with the support of the
Russian aviation Syrian military forces
conduct targeted operations to ensure
the security of the civil population
within the distillation zone Russian
side is still committed to the search
memoranda of 17th of September 2018
regarding the creation of the
demilitarization zone and we believe
that it should not be however used as
pretext for protection and covering up
for terrorists which were recognized as
such by the Security Council of the UN
and we expect that our Turkish partners
will also take into consideration this
memorandum and to use it as guiding
light in their actions and we also see
increasing preoccupation regarding the
attempts to separate the northeastern
Syria and our approach has not changed
we're still all for long-term stability
and security and the northeastern part
of Syria and believe in results of
dialogue of Damascus with curses in the
interest of Syrian people and since
Russia declared its initiative for
summer last year the over 360,000 people
returned to Syria and all of them
obviously receive help and support in
order to go back to a normal life
already on the territory where they have
always lived before and hello
humanitarian tract we continue working
on the dissemination of the IDPs camp
and our town and today we have evacuated
over 18,000 people from there and until
the end of August with the support of
your instructions we hope to finish the
withdrawal of peaceful population seal
population from broken and as far as the
IDP camp alcohol is concerned
unfortunately we do not see any positive
dynamic in this respect this camp
continues to be some kind of prison
under the open sky and we see an
increase in infectious diseases there
they still lack basic necessities and
medicine and the situation in this camp
only strengthened the radical and
extremist views of the radical
population of this inhabitants of the
people that are there who have been
radicalized and this specifically
concerns the youth we call upon the
international society to focus its
efforts on post-conflict reconstruction
and providing humanitarian support to
all Assyrians without any exceptions and
political requisites and here we see
that there's need for a financial
support for the UN mass as it has been
done by Russia and in political aspect
we are optimistic and think that there
are all the prerequisites for bringing
together constitutional committee which
would give a start to the negotiations
between Syrians on the future of their
country and as it is stated by the
resolution 2254 of the Security Council
of the United Nations and on our part we
will continue giving support to the
special envoy of the secretary-general
of the UN mr. Patterson in forming this
committee and now going to Libya we
continue receiving very worrying news
from there and despite the initiative of
the special envoy of the
secretary-general of the UN the and that
it was stated that there would be a
ceasefire for the Muslim holiday Eid
al-adha we saw some surges in violence
on 10th of August in Benghazi terrorists
blew up
a car filled with explosives as a result
three members of the UN mission on
support mission in Libya lost their
lives and over ten people were wounded
and we saw a new turn of escalation at
the negotiations at the emergency
meeting in the Security country Council
and we talked about various terrorist
attacks which threatened the security
for Libyans and work of the
representatives of international
organizations represented in that
country and we see the that this
conflict in Libya directly plays into
the hands of terrorist and extremist
groups and in the context of this lack
of power of this vacuum and central
power and lack of effective state
structures terrorists feel more freely
day-by-day and this explosion in
Benghazi is yet another example and we
believe that putting an end to terrorism
in Libya is only possible through well
coordinated efforts of the National
patriotic forces both on the West and in
the east of the country and we often see
that the situation's communicated to the
international society and it lacks an
unfortunately clarity in phrasing and in
this respect we proceed based on the
need to make the first step and
establish a long-term ceasefire regime
and also call upon Libyan nutrient
political forces to sit down at the
negotiations table and talk about
inclusive political process with the
ultimate purpose of overcoming the
division in the country and forming
United effective state institutions
which would be capable of returning
peace and prosperity to the Libyan soil
going to Venezuela now the same
characteristic could probably apply here
to the situation there continues to be
tense and our calls to Washington to
cancel the sanctions regime at least for
the social sphere and in this respect
help to improve the human terrian
situation the country have been ignored
moreover the White House continues to
try to pressurize the people of the
sovereign state which doesn't want to
leave behind the it's priority
principles which doesn't want to end up
under management from outside and this
just deepens this dead-end situation and
we see this total blockade of Venezuela
and readiness to take any steps
necessary going to Washington to
counteract Maduro and all this rhetoric
is well known they just periodically
increase this degree of heat and the
situation is just deteriorated
intentionally and we underscore the need
to guide themselves based on the UN
Charter and state that it's inadmissible
to use unilateral measures and intervene
in the internal affairs of foreign
States but Washington continues to apply
its own rules and proceeds based on its
own interests only and in this respect
we can talk about Washington as a group
of people or some part of the political
elite not but not Washington as the
capital of an entire state because the
actions which are taking by the ministry
by the political establishment the part
that has access to administration have
nothing to do with the interests of the
people of the United States it's just
obvious because all of these actions
result in global disability nor
situation in the region and how can this
possibly be in the interests of the
people of the United States is
impossible to fathom
this can correspond to the interest of
part of the elites maybe political or
even commercial elites which are
probably involved in the energy sector
but saying something specifically is
hard to say that it's in the issues of
the entire nation although it's this
high ideals that the Washington
administration actually publicly
declares and explains it as brings it up
as its motivation and now we also like
to say that the approach which
Washington has chosen and which has been
demonstrated over the last weeks will
only result in an increase in the
contradictions in the Venezuela itself
and will push the political opponents to
some forceful confrontation so over
these weeks there's been some real
effort to take the conflict from some
bordering on negotiations staged with
international mediation why would anyone
bring the situation back to total chaos
and turn it into a story which can soon
turn into some open conflict and
transform into the stage without any
exit strategy is a huge question and
unfortunately the British are also in
line with their partners and they
continue constructing military base at
the estuary of the Essequibo River and
they say it's to fight the smuggling of
drugs and arms several dozens of the
so-called refugees from Venezuela have
all radio right there in fact those are
the people who have arrived to complete
training for the Recon and diversion
groups
in order to work in Venezuela and
destabilize the situation and commit
relevant actions from extremists to
terrorist actions at the same time the
media campaign also continues aimed at
discrediting the legal and legitimate
authorities often as well as the western
mass media purposefully spreading
information containing accusations I can
give you one of the quotes which can be
used as a slogan demonstrating the
essence of this campaign they say this
country is one of the largest drug
threats to the US and they're talking
about the Venezuela we have the official
data on the Drakh threat in the region
for example we can take a look at the
special reports made by the UN office
for Drugs and Crime and they do not wish
to look at the UN data perhaps that's
too boring for them the US authorities
give precedence to the NGOs and there
are estimations by the relevant NGOs and
the most paradoxical thing is that there
is an annual report by the US Department
of State and if they took a look at the
report itself they would see the clear
situation and they would understand what
exactly are the countries who deliver
drugs to Western Hemisphere and that is
not Venezuela
although when we're talking about in
mass media of the United States of
America they have created the slogan
that Venezuela is to blame for all the
drug hardships and threats of the region
that's absurd but they also
intentionally keep silence about the
objective success of Caracas in
countering the drug threat
2005-2013 the winds Arella bowen forces
have seized over 700 tons of drugs and
it is deeply regrettable that the US
prefers to ignore these facts which have
been confirmed by the Venezuelan
authorities and the international
authorities as well the US
administration following the established
traditions to escalate the tensions and
forceful pressure against Caracas only
makes the situation worse and adds fuel
to the fire by saying that I quote the
time for dialogue has passed it's time
to act
let me remind you that the exact same
phrase was used against Libya several
years ago the time for any dialogue and
any ways of negotiation is over it is
time to act and now nobody knows how to
settle the situation in Libya and how to
make it at least close to negotiations
the slogan is still alive and now it is
used against Venezuela we can see the
such statements counterproductive
reckless and historically tested
unreliable and we also had the words of
the USA a force commander mr. fuller
concerned the development of the aid
plan for Venezuela after the resignation
of Medora once again we've seen this
before
I do not believe and I refuse to believe
that the Trump administration which as
such special attention to the Obama
administration heritage seem to ignore
the fact that Obama spearheaded the plan
for aiding Syria after assets
resignation why repeat mistakes made in
Syria and the mistakes made by the
people who do you not wish to follow it
is clear that the illegitimate
Venezuelan authorities will not conduct
these
dialogue in the conditions of blackmail
they have a pistol aimed at their head
by the US we consider it necessary to
maintain a constructive atmosphere
around the Oslo process we underlined at
the resumption of the talks of the
political opponent would be impossible
without understanding and restrained by
the responsible members of the world
community and we call on the foreign
States and Venezuelan politicians to
continue finding wasteful political
solution through inclusive dialogue
without ultimatums and preliminary
conditions now moving on to Ukraine and
the situation in Donbass in the recent
week the number of shellings by the
Ukrainian armed forces in spite of the
truce has significantly increased
although everyone expected the opposite
it is possible that the goal of this
stabilization is an attempt to provoke
return fire of the militias and declare
once again about that Donetsk and
Lugansk are to blame for breaking the
truce such massive shellings and such
scale of the destruction of military are
already civilian infrastructure
including the housing objects and so on
had not been seen even before the
declaration of the comprehensive and
indefinite summer truce starting from
the 21st of July 20 houses were
destroyed or damaged in 14 cases the
Ukrainian armed forces were using
mortars of various calibers firing over
all over 60 mines so much for a truce on
the 12th of August following mortar
shelling in their accounts effective
October 14 houses were destroyed or
damaged their power line and a gas
pipeline war destroyed the armed forces
of Ukraine were seen to be using these
strike drones reform attacks against the
civilian towns and villages according to
our information on the 12 of August
two of such drones were downed by the
people's militias of the donetsk and
lugansk people's republics this is
absolutely atrocious the fact that's
school number 13 carl FK is constantly
being shelled this is not a myth and not
a fake this fact was reported by the
special monitoring mission of the OSC on
the 9th of August and if the Ukrainian
president is so concerned by the
situation in Donbass as he said during
an emergency briefing on the 7th of
August why didn't he ask the law in
forces and armed forces to investigate
this fact as he not have control over
them once again we have the public
statements and even if he doesn't have
the whole Authority perhaps he should
start with the tools that he has by
clearly formulating the position and
saying that such acts are unacceptable
we call in the world community not to
turn a blind eye to the events and stop
covering up for the Ukrainian military
who are deliberately destroying the
population of Donbass and now I cannot
ignore this piece of news we are moving
on to the new to the news from from the
area of absurdity well I would like to
be precise in my formulas so behind the
looking laws recently
keeve declare that Ukraine has no debt
to the Commonwealth of Independent
States and
they also quoted and the relevant
authorities in particular they quoted
Buettner saying that Kremlin supposedly
leaves no chances to Reis reclaim
control over Ukraine including using the
tools of the CIS he also said that back
in the day Ukraine used to be a member
of the CIS but they were not full
participants of the CS since they had
not signed the Charter they also said
that crane one was of the one of the
founder States but for the six
consecutive years Ukraine has not signed
any document adopted by the CI as bodies
and therefore Ukraine cannot have any
debt to the CIS since Ukraine is not a
member of the organization
once again we're talking about an
official statement although it is hard
to say which is official and which is
not let us face the facts this is
ridiculous and absurd let's take a look
at the matter of Ukraine's membership in
the organization they say that they were
a founder but since they hadn't signed
any documents this means they are not
members and have no death how is that
possible they have some ridiculous ideas
about the International structures and
international obligations so I asked the
experts to prepare information
pertaining to this in the recent years
we have seen the registered tivities of
the CIS in 2014
Ukraine refused to preside in the CIS
they recalled their politicians from the
bodies of the CIS they have
minimize their participation in the such
three bodies and then they closed down
their mission to the CAS in Minsk but
legally Ukraine continues to be a member
and participant of the CIS they receive
invitations to the secretary border
sessions they are informed about the
decisions and so on I haven't seen any
document asking the CAS authorities not
to inform and not to invite Ukraine to
the sessions moreover a couple of years
ago had the level of embassies Ukrainian
was taking part in a meeting of the
diplomatic corps in Moscow they were
taking part in the meetings they were
taking part in the launches and the
dinners and so on but in spite of the
Kiev statements saying that they intend
to break up with the Commonwealth of
Independent States there have been no
official notifications at the Executive
Council of the CIS and I would like this
to be heard in Ukraine by the people who
are trying to once again fool the public
there's no other world for this they're
trying to lie to the people Kyiv did not
officially withdraw from the relevant
councils of the CIS the fact is Kiev
understands that a formal withdrawal
from the CIS would result in breaking a
number of international treaties which
have a limited number of participants
they are only limited to the CIS member
states and the continuation of these
treaties could be useful for Ukraine
currently Ukraine has withdrawn from 15
international
treatise of this kind at the same time
Ukraine remains a member of about 12
treaties and at the same time we hear
statements by the people who associated
themselves with the authorities saying
that Ukraine is not a member of the CIS
how's that possible
as for their finance and of the CIS
activities Ukraine stopped paying its
contribution to the budget of the CIS in
2014 and the current that of Kiev to the
CAS is over 300 million rubles this is
not related with Ukraine's withdrawal
from the CIS in accordance with the
Charter this was just an independent
decision by Ukraine and there have been
no limitations on Ukraine's
participation in the CIS and I can also
say that there are no obstacles for
Ukraine's full-fledged participation in
the CAS affairs so they cannot explain
their lack of payment by their non
participation they need to find some
other excuse a plausible one preferably
in October this year's the statutory
bodies of the CIS I expected to hold
their sessions including the Council of
foreign ministers and consuls of prime
ministers and Ukraine like all the other
member states will receive the materials
and invest Asians and the agendas of the
upcoming meetings if they do not require
these materials they can send a note
saying that they do not wish to be
notified of the CIS news but there have
been no official statements and notes
and neither have there been unofficial
demands
so the CIS works completely depends on
the political will of the Ukrainian
authorities the updated authorities they
just shouldn't manipulate the
information and throwing the fake
information we have the figures and
facts and another topic unfortunately
another fake from the area of absurdity
on the 9th of August the Telegraph a
news agency from the Netherlands
published an article with a fantastic
title the Russians intimidate the wives
of Dutch pilots of f-16 fighter jets
this title looks like is some option in
the computer game can you imagine the
Russians intimidating the wives of the
Dutch pilots but in fact it is a real
article in the mass media this is not a
blog this is not a social media material
this is an officially registered media
outlet citing the secret intelligence
agency data the newspaper reports
supposes threats from the Russian
intelligence against the military
servicemen of the forward presence
forces of NATO in the Baltics the cases
of intimidation were seen against the
families of the pilots of Dutch f-16
fighter jets stationed in Lithuania in
2017 and they give so-called proof the
words of anonymous witnesses who
supposedly whole heard voices on the
phone with a strong Russian accent the
fact that the pronunciation is
identified exactly as Russian rather
than Slavic or Eastern European
or anything else only means yes and let
me remind you also that we're talking
about the people who were supposedly
intimidated while in Lithuania so coming
back the fact that the article directly
talks about the Russians and says
directly that there are facts from
anonymous sources who supposedly heard
the voices on the phone with a Russian
accent all of this means that this is a
deliberate and atrocious spread of
subjective information or rather this
information with the sole purpose to
designate Russia as an aggressor in
spite of the absurdity of the article
they provide such absolutely absurd
materials I cannot call them facts
moreover the newspaper
I cannot read this but I have to I quote
they relate to the non-disclosed
verified data of the Military
Intelligence and Security Service this
looks like some kind of a parody of a
detective story they make a reference to
the information the authenticity of
which cannot be verified they only quote
anonymous sources and non-disclosed data
from the intelligence community we
regret to know that the insufficiency
and the absurdity of the supposed body
of evidence was not an obstacle to
publish an openly anti-russian material
it's not just a fake it's an
anti-russian fake this is a combination
of the propaganda
cliches and anti-russian rhetoric and we
evaluate this publication by Ag
Telegraph as an intentional introduction
of fake information aimed at
discrediting Russia and we believe that
such paranoid statements about Russian
threat which are continuously introduced
in the minds of Western audience as
libelous and unfounded and obviously we
will send a corresponding letter to this
publication and we'll present it at on
our website as an example of
publications with unreliable information
and we will use this as yet another
proof of information campaign aimed
against us and I'm ready to take your
questions if you have any yes please but
please stay seated and talk into the
microphone because we have cameras
behind you please turn on the microphone
and then the write articles about this
and every time they say that people have
hopes for reunification with Russia and
how does this correlate with news is
correct and human when people have such
hopes and who instill such hopes
and there they wait for this to take
place I have a question I often talk to
representatives of Donbass and this
takes place during meetings like the one
we have today we meet with the
representatives of the regions which ask
questions and they usually begin with
words of gratitude towards Russia and
quite often we hear
well not reprimands but maybe requests
or maybe something bordering on
desperation well maybe I would not say
that but some special hopes that they
will not be forgotten and I would like
to say that a year ago I would probably
agree with you that people had this
feeling that maybe now they think
differently about them maybe they have
been forgotten and they understand the
amount of humanitarian aid and the
amount of support moral or political
that Russia gives them in order to
implement the Minsk agreements and
during my meetings with the Donbass
Representatives last summer we've been
asked that the attention is diminishing
and they asks whether they will be
abandoned but I don't hear this after
this year in spring I was public ated
but published the plan the program on
support for the population of donbass
which was which consisted in the special
status
of this population and we received lots
of words of support in the form of
letters and feedback and I heard it
today - can we talk now that Russia has
tricked them and has tricked them with
the hopes and is giving them some ideas
that in the future proved to be some
empty hopes and some unfounded
expectations I think our policy in this
sphere has been continuous and as you
know unfortunately it's being distorted
in when it's represented in western mass
media when they don't see the idea
behind what it's being done they don't
see the that this concerns the future of
a whole region that when they pose it as
some imperial ambitions of Russia and so
on and so forth and despite this biased
view of this anti Russian campaign
despite the sanctions which many of
which are motivated by our position
regarding this topic we never stopped
providing help and I talk about
humanitarian and political help and aid
and we defend the rights of the
population of Donbass we had never
stopped doing that for a single day and
of course there are no meetings in the
format of Normandy for but who would we
be realizing them with you know what's
happening in Ukraine now and the topic
the approach to this topic and the
efforts to defend this topic is the
focus of special attention of our
ministry and our foreign missions in
international organizations and here we
talk about practical steps
and about some solid work along those
lines so if you have any specific
examples apart from some political
slogans that something has not been done
I am ready to talk about that but a year
ago and the main reason for those
complaints but no other complaints but
some desperation was but we want to
become cross the citizens we cannot
leave the tissue we have no documents
Kiev has blocked everything starting
with the payment system and all the way
up to transportation means please do not
forget us well today everything that
could have been done in order to help
people get rid of this status of
hostages and get out of this situation
of some isolated existence will have all
the opportunities to leave and to move
around although I perfectly understand I
have mentioned this data what they tried
to do is to try to annihilate them
completely from the face of the earth
and there is not a single aspect
regarding which Russia will inspire some
empty hopes would give some promises was
not intending to keep and would not be
accompanying with some practical steps
actually on the contrary maybe we talk
less about that when then we should
maybe it's my personal opinion maybe
it's some national tradition first to do
the deed and then talk about it rather
than first promise and then not complete
this promise and I think we do a lot and
we do it despite this colossal
mainstream disapproval for Russian steps
although it completely
is in line with the agreements which we
have achieved through Normandy for and
it is completely in line with the Minsk
agreements and it is in line with the
human rights and defense of human Aryan
values which our Western partners were
defending so much and who are the
authorities for Kiev at least have been
such over the last couple of years this
is the line of declarations which Kiev
has been making lately associating
itself with the West in this aspects any
further questions in researching car in
work media over the last weeks in
kirgizia there's been some unsettling
situation kirgizia is among the top ten
partners of the Orenburg region and
secondly our region for qgz is a transit
region even the Kyrgyz citizens which
going to Moscow pass through our region
and given the political crisis there
does ministry have any preoccupations
regarding the trade and economic
cooperation a trade yes do you have any
preoccupations that there might be
refugees from Kuki xia refugees yes
migration of refugees as far as your
first question is concerned here this
should probably not be the statement
from the Minister of Foreign Affairs
but rather information from financial
and economic cooperators I don't have
this data that there are some serious
problems which cannot be solved and that
the operators are facing and that this
is some global difficulty I don't have
this information I could double-check
but at the moment I do not have this
data and as far as your question
regarding the situation now overall
we've given our evaluations and now we
see that in this er that formed the
manifestations of the instability that
we've seen their they are diminishing at
least we see some kind of stabilization
in the region we can say that and the
internal stability in qgz obviously is
an interest of its nation of the
population as well as the interest of
neighboring countries and we expect that
the situation will be will be revolved
according to the international law and
hopes for stabilization full
stabilization of votes to earlier to
talk about that but the efforts will
continue and we will give our experts
opinion regarding the visits to this
country and will do so if the situation
should require it and as far as refugees
and so and so forth are concerned that's
why we defend the idea of stability and
this is our approach not only to Kyrgyz
eeeh we perfectly understand it and
we've seen it in different regions that
internal conflicts that are often a
pretext for various countries to fish
for fish in those unsettled waters
result in the situation when the
conflict grows from an internal to
regional and when it surpasses its
borders and that's why we insist so much
and so clearly state our position in
favor of internal stability in this
country yes please
good afternoon rude out TV they've been
negotiations between the u.s. and Turkey
regarding the creation of a security
zone in the northern and eastern Syria
between home and home the US and Turkey
recently and I believe they agreed to
create an escalation zone in the eastern
Syria but I didn't quite understand what
is Russia's position regarding the
creation of such a zone there but I have
rather clearly talked about this today
when I was giving my evaluation of the
situation in Syria and the situation in
this region overall that we do not
accept any separation of the regions of
this country under any critics
whatsoever obviously we see
counter-terrorist activity but first and
foremost it should be coordinated with
Damascus this is the first and
undeniable a prerequisite and secondly
we understand that neighboring countries
have their own interests and that the
situation is too complicated to evaluate
classify it in simple terms but this
brings us back to the point one
everything that happens on the Syrian
soil has to be done based on the
agreement of the government of the
country and not no reason whatsoever can
be a respectful enough reason to
separate isolate certain region let
alone to freeze it for further
requalification or separation division
or redistribution of Syria you know this
and this is our position which we have
stated continuously and this is based on
which we proceed
and another question regarding
operations so which turkey plans in the
to the eastern side of your Freitas and
the northern Syria do you think they
should cooperate them with Damascus in
any case they should there cannot be a
situation when our position is applied
to 99 percent of operations which take
place with participation of third
countries and I'm talking about the
situation in Syria that they have to be
coordinated but one percent can go
without coordination everything has to
be green lighted by the country this is
the territory where various interest
meets meet and this includes national
and foreign interests but this never
cancels out the interests of Syria of
sovereign Syria
moreover Damascus and official
government of the country has proved
that it is capable of consolidating the
society and it's capable of fighting
bacterium and fighting backs external
support for terrorists and I think over
these years it has really achieved
something real maybe we will not hear
this from official capitals in the West
but if this government definitely proved
that it functions and it works and we
never doubted theirs never doubted its
mandate and let alone ever ask questions
on this topic never ask ourselves
questions regarding this or ask anyone
else Damascus and Syria has always
remained a sovereign state and we've
heard lots of things including
statements about its inability to
organize consolidation of the society
it's inability to protect itself from
some terrorist groups lots of big lots
have been said some even doubted the
legitimacy of the government itself and
I think after what we've seen after what
after the way the consolidation of the
nation took place when it came to
fighting back the terrorists and from
the point of view of real efforts which
finally take some specific
characteristics the and as far as
political consolidations concerned which
was unimaginable a few years ago all
these questions are now unfounded and
it's an international law it's a
something international law requires to
respect the sovereign state and the
sovereign state requires a certain
respect certain approach and all
operations have to be coordinated with
Damascus obviously we are in contact
with our Turkish partners and some
issues have been settled some are in the
process right now but this does not
cancel out the idea that Syria as a
sovereign state should control rule and
have full rights to decide what it's
happening on its soil but once again
this is our standard stance and it has
not changed over these years despite all
that's happened despite what some say
that does not correspond to the reality
that it's impossible now it's possible
why not do you have any further
questions yes please a human tear in
question in orbic region
we have a migrant infant in one of our
hospitals it needs an operation do you
have any cooperation with Pakistan to
provide such help yes when I was
preparing to visit Orenburg I studied
the events or hot-button issues related
to international agenda and what you
just mentioned was something I learned
as part of my preparation this is a
humanitarian case wait I'll try to find
this material which I should have and I
do have it here we are talking about a
situation when a citizen of his back is
done I have her name but I will not be
using it at the briefing and will not be
posting it publicly we'll just process
information to the Uzbek embassy we will
send the information using diplomatic
channels the situation is as follows a
citizen I was Becca Stan who was located
on the territory of the Orenburg region
was pregnant and she was not on any
medical supervision so she came to the
Orang birth
birth center she was unemployed and she
did not have any identifying papers or
documents but since she needed medical
help she received it thanks to the
medics of Orenburg so an important event
happened in the life of this woman from
Uzbekistan and for his Becca Stan as a
whole a child was born on the 7th of
August but unfortunately the child had
severe heart condition this is a problem
which accordance to in according to the
doctors requires the surgery so as the
local medical experts say this surgery
should be performed within the first
three weeks of the infant's life and now
this is a matter of the legal
formalities about the paperwork about
finding the finances for the surgery
since the mother had no documents she
was unemployed but she received in
necessary medical assistance
but now treatment is required for her
child I think this topic will be seen by
the representatives of as Becca Stan in
our country we will share our
information with them to make sure this
situation is resolved yes please more
questions
Anton Sybil of the Orenburg regional
media invest company a matter a question
about the infrastructure perhaps it does
not pertain to the foreign ministry but
still they work on the border
checkpoints Orenburg has six of them
the master comments are seen are the two
main ones so
of these checkpoints are overloaded the
infrastructures too old and technically
obsolete during peak hours it has many
people many cargo cars and many
kilometers of queues and drivers are
forced to spend several days waiting to
clear the border and at best the repair
works and updates will begin in 2021 and
it is not clear whether the checkpoints
will go through thorough updating and
repairs since the system of the
development of the transport highways
and links of the New Silk Road is not
clear yet so my question is is the
foreign ministry aware of the situation
and is there a link but with Kazakhstan
because both the Russian and the Kazakh
checkpoints should be repaired and
updated when will this be done I can
definitely tell you that the Russian
Foreign Ministry is aware of the
situation our experts are working on the
infrastructure projects which are being
developed on the territory that you
mentioned and in we cooperate with the
neighboring countries including the
neighbors of the region where we are
located I can assure you that the
opening of border checkpoints is not a
matter of the foreign ministry since we
do not open the border checkpoints we
have other services for that but I can
get back to you if you leave me your
contact information do you have other
questions if there are no questions this
is a goodbye and I would like to say
that we will not stop at Orenburg August
is a time for travel and we were invited
to attend another Youth Forum which will
take place in Petit Gorsky so the next
briefing on the 22nd of August will take
place in pitty Gorsky where from the 9th
to the 30th of August the 10th North
Caucasus used for a mushrik will take
place it will bring together about 3000
not
young people from the Northern Caucasus
as well as other regions of the Russian
Federation and the neighboring countries
the detailed information about the form
and the accreditation for the
journalists will be available at the
foreign ministry website so see you
there in petty garzke see you good bye